hello I'm Sam this is my channel this is
that Wikipedia list and this is that
Wikipedia list
you can't copy money I don't mean it's
illegal
that's obvious I mean that you
physically cannot copy money on a
photocopier this is probably the only
thing in the world that your copier will
simply refuse to copy with pretty much
any modern copier an error message will
come up if you put a bank note or
something resembling a bank note in the
scanner I tell you to try it but there
are so many laws surrounding currency
that I'm pretty sure I'd have the police
kicking down my door tomorrow if I did
you can just take my word for it it's
pretty interesting how money is detected
by photo copiers for almost any major
currency there's one symbol that tells
machines that what they're seeing is
money it's called the Orion
constellation and it looks like this it
was first discovered on the 10 euro note
in this cluster of circles but has since
been found on the American dollar the
Swedish Krona the UK pound and pretty
much every other major currency most
photo copiers will if they see this
pattern of dots stop printing in an
attempt to stop counterfeit at least
that's how it used to be more recently
copiers have moved to a system called
the counterfeit deterrent system which
is incredibly secretive and effective
nobody is really sure how it works
and while the Euro Ryan constellation
might be part of it these security
measures make it even more difficult to
copy banknotes Adobe Photoshop like most
photo editing software's has the
counterfeit deterrent system built-in
which lets you see just how well it
works Photoshop can of course detect
this image of a ten-pound note since
it's you Ryan constellations are clearly
visible but then it can also detect it
if the area is blacked out it can even
figure out that this tiny almost
completely blacked out image is part of
a u.s. $20 bill and refuse to edit it
there's a ton of different laws relating
to the duplication and publication of
visuals of currency the US has 32 pages
of laws related to currency along with
the obvious
of counterfeit it's also illegal in the
u.s. to print or publish any
illustration of currency postage stamps
or revenue stamps of any nation in the
world unless of course it's a stamp made
under the migratory bird hunting Stamp
Act of 1934 and no that's not a joke
it's also illegal to deface currency in
any way or to use the image of currency
in any advertisement it is however legal
to show authentic banknotes in videos
and films for this reason in most cases
the money used in movies is real -
legally create prop money the bill has
to be less than 75 percent or more than
150 percent of the size of authentic
currency one-sided and must be destroyed
immediately after use unless they want
to do something that's illegal with
money like Burnet or otherwise to face
it filmmakers will often use real money
just for simplicity sake some prop
manufacturers will create a stack of
blank green paper then top it with one
real bill to give the appearance of
stacks of currency in conclusion don't
mess around with counterfeit it will
almost never end well thank you for
watching sorry for the short episode but
I wanted to get something out this week
right now I'm working on three or four
videos that I'm very excited about to be
released in the coming weeks and months
so make sure to click Subscribe to catch
those you can also follow me on twitter
at Wendover pro for updates along the
way